[music]
zero 2
[music] My
nails are starting to peel off and I
'm covered in scratches I don't have
time I have to make a
lot of them
I don't know why you're so obsessed with being human
00 Taxes are zero2 It doesn't matter where you were born It doesn't matter if you're amazing or fang Even
better, I was attracted to you just the way you are  It
doesn't matter if you're human or not I
've always wondered what it feels like to be 0 years older than you I
realized when I saw Goro and Tao This feeling is different from others
I like you 00
I like you the way you are I like you
What's
that
?  Take it all out It's
not enough
Kill more monsters and make me human You're my food